I have the honor of being the executive
secretary of the United Nations
Convention on Climate Change why am I
here because this is my life's work
what's important about this cop is to
set a very very clear direction as well
as recognize that the direction needs to
be coupled with urgency a good deal will
a protect the most vulnerable be be fair
to all countries they bring everyone on
board not leave anyone behind sea send a
signal to the private sector to capital
markets to research and technology that
they need to accelerate the shift and
see established the process throughout
which over the next 10 to 20 years we
will be able to truly tell whether we
are progressing or not so a sense of
transparency of measurement of progress
with milestones and a predictable long
term target there is not a single person
around in in the world right now that is
not already affected by climate change
we need to know that it is a reality as
much as oxygen is our reality and it's
going to get worse and we all have a
shared responsibility here to a adapt to
the the worst environment that we're
going to have but also make sure that we
do everything within our power to avert
the worst impacts because it is the most
vulnerable that will be forced it
you